having heard this explanation now you
probably think that punch cards were
invented probably by IBM in the very
earliest era of computers roundabouts
shall we say the late forties early
fifties actually I think they were
invented by IBM but a lot earlier than
that and particularly somebody who was
very much involved in the early days of
computing and tabulating machinery man
called Herman Hollerith and if you look
into the history of Hollerith codes and
Hollerith punch cards you find that they
were absolutely bound up with doing the
United States Census if you're taking a
census of your population every I think
it's every 10 years in the UK probably
the same in the u.s. you rapidly find as
your population gets into the tens or
hundreds of millions even that you
cannot do it all by hand you just have
to be able to punch a card for every
person or something of that sort and be
able to have tabulating machines not
actually computers but if you like
simplified electromechanical sorting and
collating machines that would pick up
the holes in the punch card and enable
simple numerical processing to be done
but very much in an electromechanical
kind of way and those of you with
slightly longer memories or slightly old
and they well remember that I think up
until about two elections ago in the
u.s. there was a grave distrust of
having purely electronic voting machines
you wanted to have the fact that if you
registered your vote it was done on
punch cards and I think it was the era
of the presidential election which Al
Gore narrowly lost in Florida to George
Bush where all this came to light that
as part of Florida's polling system yeah
you had punch card machines you punched
a card you know Carlos punch to say who
you were card was punch to say what your
vote
but when things went wrong and the
counting showed that she was result too
close to call I'd certainly room on the
newsreels people holding up cars very
similar to this but not using this code
and talking about the fact that perhaps
one or two of these holes have not being
punched correctly if you have a worn
card punch you can get two possibilities
you can get one of these windows is ever
so slightly closed because the little
piece of card at the back which is
technically known as a Chad had not
become properly detached so did that
count as a punched hole or not because
if it didn't then maybe this is an Al
Gore vote or if the hell was punched out
maybe it was a George Bush wrote and
even worse I think than the hanging
chads were the dimpled Chad's once again
if you get a machine that's not been
very well maintained and doesn't hammer
its way so this card you can have
situations here where you don't get a
clean hole you just get an indentation
in the cardboard and it's not a proper
punched hole at all
so I do remember the user is being full
of analysis of hanging chads and dimpled
Chad's and this would go to the Supreme
Court I think it did I think that the
judges in soon Preem court ended up
looking at these things and
pontificating about hanging chads
dimpled Chad's and who would really want
car technology then was not invented in
computers in mind or those very readily
adapted for them it was invented simply
and solely to cope with doing the United
States Census do you know and it doesn't
matter if you don't do you know what a
computer would do with a hanging Chad hi
oh that's interesting
what would a computer do with a hanging
Chad I rather suspect that's the just
the mechanism of putting these cards
through a card reader
card readers were amazingly fast I think
if there was a hanging Chad it would
tend that the compressed air
there's a lot of compressed air using
these machines to move the cars through
very quickly and as they move through
the reader station then photoelectric
cells actually would nowadays have read
those holes I think if the Chad was
hanging in the breeze it probably would
have registered as not a hole it just
depends how hanging it was and certainly
a dimpled Chad photo electrically would
not have registered as being a hole so
yeah it all depends whether these things
are being read mechanically with little
rods going through that might have
punched the Chad out or whether there
were being read photo electrically I
just don't know